all right everybody just uh let's settle
down
settle in and like just totally let's
get our math on okay
all right guys so um
somebody's got a little extra energy
from phys ed right
jimmy buddy hey buddy let's okay let's
just let's knock it off okay
you got me he got me right guys jimmy
dude
all right let's take our seat
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's great that's free that's
[Applause]
that was awesome oh and i thank you i
thank you for the entertainment man
i don't want to harsh your vibe man but
ah eureka
i'm gonna be honest with you really
pushing my buttons now
jimmy you're driving me
[Music]
you want me to write your name on the
board
hold okay jimmy do you want me to call
principal martel
that would not be bitching
you know what jimmy you know what why
don't you come up and teach the class
man
hmm wouldn't that be awesome
yeah come on
[Laughter]
no and then you know what i'm gonna do
jimmy i'll just sit here how about that
jimmy and then we can all watch
how you're being disrupted
oh i see that's supposed to be me right
all right jimmy okay i see that i get it
supposed to be me it's time to be done
jimmy
don't you dare johnny
oh yeah oh yeah
well this is you jenny
[Laughter]
give me five huh how about that huh
that's you jimmy i'm jimmy
i'm jimmy and i need attention
yeah i'm jenny i'm jimmy hello look at
that
happy movie that's the
mr flyer principal martel no what
no no no no no it was jimmy it was jimmy
principal martel
no jimmy why yeah it was jenna hey
it was jimmy it was jimmy
[Applause]
[Music]
terry
[Applause]
[Music]
you